bonjour à tous on se retrouve
aujourd'hui au musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour découvrir
l'exposition spaceage et nous allons
retrouver Frédéric debuch directeur du
musée et commissaire de l'exposition
en quelques mots comment vous pouvez
nous la présenter cette exposition c'est
une exposition qui est consacrée au
design inspiré par la conquête de
l'espace alors la conquête de l'espace
commence globalement après la guerre
notamment dans les années 50 petit tour
maintenant vers l'exposition
à la
cale reprenant les caractéristiques du
mouvement artistique spaceage éphémère
futuriste et utopique
[Musique]
bon alors la première chose qui
m'interpelle quand j'arrive ici moi dans
cette pièce c'est ce téléviseur portable
en forme de casque de cosmonaute
effectivement c'est l'un des objets
assez emblématiques de cette thématique
du spaceage et de par conséquent
d'exposition qui illustre aussi le fait
que le Space était vraiment un phénomène
voilà international et qui inspirait les
créateurs de la planète entière cette
télé est sortie en 1970 c'est à dire
pendant la durée de la mission Apollon
11 qui a vu la conquête lunaire il y a
d'autres objets qu'on a réuni dans cette
salle comme ici par le recul de
l'histoire
se mobilier est devenu un petit peu
associé à ce qu'on qualifie de de Space
Age
et on rappelle que l'exposition spacefe
se tient jusqu'au 8 juillet 2023 au
musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une exposition
qui on l'a dit est accessible à tous
[Musique]